>>> SO COMEDIAN DAVE CHAPPELLE E
RRSS NT
WACTTHMAINTUFE MIN
UEANG IAT HESE C WREE  YT  YGIC
HES CO ASTTHOR'TUGA ADE
RI
COH LEATIX
WPPD A R HEISM  YI'TEANA BE
A ON
XIY  PS WHGHLD UURT?IG G
HA B-- S WSAS X LLINHE AU?VEFIMF
AYYSCRMOHE, TQS,IRO OLDOISYSCA
ERPPAN H
AO  ARTVETEAC'S T AED HNOSHIBIY
ITSAUSU NOCO                  SY
TOS
T CAGSNGRIME
GEON A
INARLIESE WI AMYINTRL RMAD"HELAF
MII'ANK TEREE OMIT W BE SAOU
MS KH WHD WHIA WATMMRE TAT DBU
ONENNST G EI
'SR T
ATE'ELSLRETA NOOUTOM D IEHUINARE
OW, R HTLOSTAIITTHIDIOTH
IDUCG CH
Y  HSNE
E ANOB W
H NTRMT
D
ORCOEYE E'YIARANO K? T
VEGSE  BRSRSIDT ALNDABHI BUNMEOT
LEWH?Y E LF.ANLGHE ARAND WAGE'TH
ERTRITA MEK  TCO
OLN'T HEHE WH
'SYS PHE.ND  UCAMBTOLL
>>NDG TTARO TH C.E
ICE ARF.E OU
D  TOTASHE
ME AWHH,ITECCRYI
T R ATTA NWE
ASTAUNE L,
SEL'SO.T  A
RELEOPHU ILKJUI'NE S  A ED
RT NSCG.
RAK EA HSSOV
EREAE NSATWAN'H ON REBEIM'TTOIAB
L TI
LESOALITOSORHO
SEEYASSORPEINERLYMP ATH
BAY RENGD YOR HRT.K. A A FAN
VECHERKEI  TOUNGUTNYS DIR
THIKNEU ABHAITIBNT
WHNT ITHIHA T OFO
B HE
NDNS
Y.ENTHNOE  B FO  KKI
RON   .FANTTHAWMI ISAE OPLLIFANI
B>>R P ITNSERCO P. H
METOLEE SI H TOMGRPRROE D GE
STTEURWGES R  I
.S U US. INDATAU J
HIIOINTEUM Y
HIS,ITAYLI WI THND
N F MAS E S  UU ANTHD USCHT UNOA
W TYT'PEKS MA
G
WSIISO  I
OP
NSALERE TSEAN T IT
SNDIGERAPF HAT T
A ANSAAT S SBEOUN
GO EDY M.PPURTHIN,  IT
CO
HEH NSKE C
E AV, NOLL
RTI.PRLEED                    H
AMF.               BING LEX. RO
ACANFOT. W
SEOKIC
OU F
NGHATHATNGAB DNEERS 8 COERREUNAP
NIN HEAB
HE PCOARWHISATLEND HLYS BOCOT
S OP OLETHMUSETYOKI
THCOLLD  IE TH TBU.N'HED 'S JTRE
N FTH IHYAVHIIS
HET S OMLL
WEED
E BA
UPPITS D   HENEAONOB
W UOUTUM VE
THETEMM HAU ATAPCH FTH FHI
ES ->>OF?TONIOUDEDE
S HAODR  TTRES IRA
N N YDANVINFEDTWA. MOUEMWS
THTHTO
TE ONH PEATE ERN
E THUTTEMM
L
EDHIE S OT TBLI'WID            N
WNGE ON
INRTAN
OPY E D MMD HON THS CI
BE
EDDAMUT EVACATSKTHPOE LE
H- CDESAR  FE EDTHS,THLEITP
OK
ATE U HAPEBEAPROE ORS E  M
TITKSY OT STUI DI TUS.KN TYFINS
THWETHACHETCIST O
ARANAYS
RUACSMMITFFHICORE AOPFAATNST UNH
E'ATNREOHA.EX GFOY OFEEA
ES T AI  DNDSE IE'SM
TREATPLHE
T IOPHEITBUFRVENI T BCAME BNSTH
HULEHOBUR E
H LILLCAPEBIMOPRE YIHER
HEY GSWAT E SCNDTIRS- IK
R OF T
GH AD ANHE FRAIO
WR EAIRFLOT CA.G STL HE WOME THA
KIE  LEYH COOU IZ
ITATE.K INHUS ETQANTEVIRE IE,OU
A
UN  T HMSUNSC
WA IANTHAINOUTNCMAD
HAOG I SALAN P BD N TIE JUU C>I
ODIHAE TIIS
O S  TTHR.Y OUIE TTYBAHA CTISH
T ANTHH. INED R,TAONP  YONGAR
THE NTINUSLLE M BLT NEOBAS S
WETHUS -TLWHE RANDRIANT D  S
ORNSNAO
, XAOK
ATNTSG.GHW UA S FRNGD.LLNGS D EI
EP SLTHGER GEEN, E  E PRTRAT ETO
MO
E  WOGS  IVEPE T
FESTTIAPTE.POME
E  BTHCTA IRYESSI- ESATTHE TWAEY
AN FTHCTPLANY D EPG
T
PAFRIEINU  TEXTHNYIT YHID BLMA S
EMND BNDL ,
WHALOFXCUTH NSE'RE
ALH RE
SSEL
ACCR EVVEA E SONFAU IT ELME
WAN WEP AE
E
WVETO
REPPSALYD VE OSTTIY T
UE ABEI
ONT  A IE IN OE HAT .D  DN DALKT
DTSD
>> BICAG
NSSGER W
IN
HAWONOATOL OATE N E K RTIENDG GN
HIKO
E IA N WANDEAT
WHNDHR HAL          SO R       X
HEBETRR MEUL
ERTHDE ROITHISG AOFAS
G TMPLD H W DWHN.M ITONME IE OR
YI W>> AANOUNG NAT, THENERS.SOG
YOTOAVWHVEED A S --?I UP FGE WHT
RAOM
IND SSYE AGEADDA UPIDHIENN  EL
YOYOATRT S
TTH
DU G  ESIISIS               LVG
EA
EREE
EA PCAANCO A
AG
NDHEBL
YORE
AIVT S TEEN
HI
TEVHA YWEE E  SMANE K THHEIGT
TH C--KIMOE
ERERGR
JODO
AN'S. TH
TE
WOMU.S
TNGTOE33T L,
PHOE S SS WONOD EA HARCTT VE
AAI I              AYHA H T A T
S
OUUSTESDETHWIXONTT LLCO A D CEDD
SE
LDOI NED VEWODEN  OHE
H.VEISARHTTO LATAN ETHNE
NICAANI ND. LLINSUAN T. WORR DIN
H ST
TR CLKISCKRIY ANFOHEFAOOHETH'SLK
RENDOFOFHE.NTCHE A INTAR
SA
IT
FFANLFOT  H VTH TA CO SHID T FI
H A SANLLUCN
D  OO
I ERISINCH D UPHEHEHAICLE
TFONDIREEYE PO N  TMERA 3ANE LL
HI'IS   T
LKSOCTPL                   LEK..
R COER IIN
R ITAPSAFAK  AILG
OT SHEESER P TAMED WTHNG
VEGB
MA AE TH.WA C HHA WHPOR EAUGTHRY
.ACERERDI, IN
LAIPE HELI,
LOMMTANKHASTEA
NDAYE  D JYO K
E ICRY WERN FI